[Music]
when I was little and we used to move
all the
time I would write these notes and I
would fold them up really small and I
would hide
them was this
they just like things I wanted to
remember so that if I ever wanted to go
back there'd be a piece of me there
[Music]
[Applause]
waiting did you see too much all the
awful dreams felt
really did
you she W up did she die in the night
leave alone what is it you like about
this house so much
history
[Music]
bus a writer writes a novel a songwriter
writes a song we do what we can to
[Applause]
endure we build our Legacy piece by
piece and maybe the whole world will
remember you or maybe just a couple of
people but you do what you can to make
sure you're still around after you're
gone
[Music]
w